according to Egypt this week sentenced
for men
up to eight years in prison for yeah
homosexuality
prosecutors had accused the men
upholding quote deviant parties
and they're using a law that bans
debauchery
to to put these guys in jail and put
them on trial
at the middle east seems to be pretty
backward as we've talked often about
related to anything with human rights
women's rights gay rights that are there
we've got a map that give you a little
more
about gay rights around the globe and
basically
red and the darker red you are the worse
it is blue in the darker blue you are
the better it is and and grey
it's pretty it's pretty decent I'm how
do we
get the Middle East into the 21st
century
I get it we're not perfect here we do
not have for marriage equality here we
got plenty of problems here
but how do we get that section of the
world to at least come a little
that further in this direction well
funny you should say the word comin that
question my head that they look at their
own history
be chipped Kate you cleopatra who with
what are the more sexually deviant
characters in in history
apparently this woman used to have 100
the men contribute to her bout
good for her skin or whatever and I was
like that now we have an issue with
one-on-one
I was like I don't nurse I don't
understand the logic 100 amended what
contributor her bath contribute comin
about tub and she would baby and it I've
never heard that are you kidding me it's
all over the internet
yeah but
I've never so she was in a greater sense
memory like I think yeah I'm she would
be
wow I did not know that through it it
wanted she
bitch with sexually deviant whether or
not that I like a mythological whatever
your own immunity idol like
in every II look at all these
conservative culture even like Asian
me outlets you know a lot of players
myself Chinese history there somewhere
to ship that went down and then they're
like
all know gay people know gay people are
like really am because the all the time
came yeah shit back in your dynasty in
the NRL
Yap do we have any right to take it to
the quest to help
I'm not sure that had a nice morning I
don't get them to look at their own
history in Riyadh
the hypocrisy in you know that where did
we come from where we going
well I guess that in the case and yet so
if that's a place where science
and the liberalism were rewarded a
little more a long time ago and they've
sorted
gone backwards do we have any bright in
the United States
to tell these people had a live 1900
YouTube commenters are going to say no
cuz everytime I pose that question
everyone yeltsin's as you know right we
need to mind their own dinner it's a
difficult yeah
which should we care about the their
human rights well I think we should my
my we are human beings and we are tied
by that threat by
ate the most viewed country is Saudi
Arabia which is
interest right on that map in Colorado
you know in and
it's amazing I think what's being done
on YouTube not that we're saving the
world are curing cancer
or you know but I think it is a stout
in a journey towards getting people to
move a little bit forward with the way
that they
you gay rights do you get a lot of
comments from
for people from Saudi Arabia nah party
rockers we did a video last week about
women driving in saudi arabia
and I actually got a lot of men from
Saudi Arabia angry
saying that women shouldn't be allowed
to drive in if you let women drive is
going to be more car accident or so
and I kinda feel bad for them more than
anything else because they're just being
indoctrinated
break with this stuff and so it's like I
can't hate
am really because that's what they're
being talk but you get a lot of comments
on your videos I didn't want to be males
from people that are in countries where
it's like not as accepted but the
the important thing is that you're
starting a dialogue when you're starting
a conversation that they might not
otherwise have
yeah family is it going to solve all the
problems and no but maybe it's going to
get the ball moving a little bit
yeah is there anything that the
government should do I mean should we be
each it is our ally we give them a lot
of money
should that be contingent on human
rights I think
I think we should tread carefully cuz I
don't understand what's going on
in the you when it comes to business
affairs I don't run this country and not
a policymaker because I know there's a
lot
policymaker I trench and I thought I
already said policy-making hear them to
me neighbor to make it worth it to me
out what you know i mean there's a lot
that goes on %um
we don't know how we'll wheeling and
dealing with between his world leaders
and I think in order to protect American
interests we have to tread carefully
when we turn as in other peoples
business
but without being fed human to human I i
think thats why we do what we do because
I like reaching people on a personal
level I to get a lot have
people in these very conservative
country is
including the Middle East as well as
parts of Asia who in the closet and are
scared
and I do what I can from that level by I
and that that's the only thing I'm able
to do at this point
yeah well I get around as their little
part by the way we should note that gay
cities which is a big a website
they did their poland what the best gay
city is in the world and last year
it was tel-aviv Israel just smack in the
middle the Middle East what is with
those crazy jus their hair down
with the gays while everybody else
around them seem to want to kill
up